good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Monday hope everybody had a glorious
weekend speaking of Glory it's Jax a
glorious gal wow thank you later dalu I
did I mean if you wanted to you could
call me Gloria
Gloria Gloria everybody used to sing
that song to me when I was a kid like
Claudia Claudia and honestly I have a
lot of love for that song and Gloria
Estefan it's very apt I thought you were
going to be like they were singing and
they were singing it wrong like no she
might as well have been saying Claudia
no they everyone adjusted with him and
sing it to me as a child they'd be like
Claudia Claudia you're always on the run
now Claudia used to be true I used to
always be on the run but you're always
on the run now because you're always in
the gym working on your Fitness no
because I'm always saying yes to life
running to the next fabulous event so
true you said yes to a lot of life this
weekend no to some other life it was a
nice balanced weekend I think for you
it was a nice balanced weekend for me as
well mostly kid time I don't think I did
anything else but I read a lot because
we're recording the new episode of the
redheads today
I love books I hope one day to have a
child who loves to read yeah and if they
do love to read I'm so happy to let you
know that my children's book comes out
in eight days we're officially in the
single digits today is Monday and it
comes out next Tuesday so tomorrow will
be one week I'm freaking out oh man I
like I knew it was coming out like in
the middle of October but I didn't
realize eight days October really snuck
up on us I feel like the first of the
month being on a weekend it just kind of
is irrelevant it snuck up on us but I'm
happy that it's here I'm happy to go
into October it's Pub month
next week is Pub week so my book the
camera and the counselor comes out on
Tuesday I'm coming to New York next week
for the pub week to you know build up be
with Claude you know there's no one else
I would rather celebrate with and I'm
planning some really fun events for the
week that I'm in town but confirmed I
can let you guys know New Jersey
toasters I am doing a book signing at
books and greetings on Saturday October
14th at 11 A.M it is in Northvale New
Jersey so it's like 20 minutes out of
the city I'm so excited to sign some
books kiss some babies meet some
toasters and also just like hang out
with the kids I tried to choose a very
kid and Mom friendly time for the book
signing because it's like the perfect
activity for a Saturday afternoon I'm
personally always looking for things to
do with my kids on the weekends and I
feel like this is going to be so fun
while you're waiting in line there'll be
fellow toasters fellow kids you can make
friends have a playdate get your book
signed it's so cute I'm so excited like
I'm genuinely excited to attend this
event if you want to secure your spot
there will be an Eventbrite link up
later today I'll post it as soon as I
have it or you can call books and
greetings in Northvale New Jersey and
secure your spot get your book and make
sure that you will be attending the
signing um that is what I'm right now
most excited for for launch week no not
me wishing now I had a kid so I could
bring him or her to the event and like
just drop him off and I'll go shopping
you know there's like tons of capable
mothers in that room somebody just
watched my kid I'm going to get a
manicure or you could come to the event
and borrow a child for a couple minutes
at a time which is your favorite it is
my favorite thing to do like find a kid
that I just connect with like a really
cute one and make him mine for a total
of 10 minutes right until your arms hurt
and you're over it right and I'm hungry
and like the kids annoying me pulling my
hair yeah
That's so exciting I'm so excited so
October 14th 11 A.M books and greetings
Northvale New Jersey more details on my
Instagram later today but you can call
them up and reserve your spot if you
really want to come it's going to be so
much fun I'm real I'm so excited we've
done so many meet and greets especially
with Sprints at the liquor store and
like my favorite ones are when there are
kids that come by of course and this is
going to be a meet and greet of all kids
I can't wait no and it's going to be a
meet and greet of all kids whose mothers
or fathers are toasters and that just
kind of hits different you know yeah
you're also welcome to come without your
child or if you don't have a child but I
just think it would be it will be so fun
for parents and children alike yeah but
if the moms like kind of have had enough
feel free to leave the kids with Dad
bring a cocktail bring a cocktail bring
a paper Uber take an Uber and relax and
hang with some toasters yeah it's really
for everyone but I'm very glad that it's
gonna be very kid-friendly yeah me too
that sounds so fun next week it's just
gonna be fabulous I can't believe it's
already here I really I think
anticipated it being the week after next
yeah so I need to like re-jigger my
whole mental state you do plus I'm doing
talk shop live next week like prepare to
be sick of me and that's how you know a
press tour is going well when everyone's
sick of you if you want me to stop just
pre-order my book the camera and the
counselor at Amazon
Goodreads Barnes and Noble books and
Hood ring Talk Shop live no it's it's
not you can't order a book on Goodreads
I just am always talking about Goodreads
so it was yeah it was the first to come
to mind Trulia Indie bound Target
Walmart wherever you want to get your
books the camper and the counselor so
excited Jax we're so excited for the
whole toast Community is kind of Ablaze
and excited to report that I finally got
copious copies of my book I had the one
since May that Harry has read to filth
and now I have a copy that I can keep in
the studio because he won't let me take
his copy up to the studio so now I can
show you and tell you the camper and the
counselor the books are here
I'll give a little sneak peek of a page
you haven't seen yet oh
you know what this is actually my
favorite page I'm gonna give you a
little peek it's the Campers at the lake
it's kind of kind of that's where the
plot kind of takes a turn it's a pivotal
moment for our camper lessons I want to
say there's kind of a a plot twist
nobody sees coming at the lake you think
when snitch does what she does yeah and
then the result of that doing it's kind
of changes the landscape of the book
completely it it really does changes you
can argue I would argue that the lake is
like a turning point I feel as though at
the lake is where the campers really
start to believe in and trust their
counselor yeah because things hadn't
gotten hard before that yeah we're all
having fun it's Camp right it is easy to
love right but no the counselor had to
do some serious counseloring at the lake
no totally also because I got copies of
my book this week and I was able to give
a copy to Michaela and Levi and Michaela
loves The Parent Trap
so I felt like I already was coming in
at an advantage like here's the book
version of your favorite movie Michaela
no like literally the outfits that the
campers are wearing are so similar to
the camp Walden yeah also camper has red
hair
oh my oh my god I didn't even put
together how
camper does camper have a name not in
the book
because it's all from her POV but this
was something that I thought about I was
like should I put her name in there was
a version where she does introduce
herself but I was like no she's just our
camper every girl she is all of us
exactly oh I love that
um
I had to put together how she's
literally Holly and Annie is she more of
a Hallie or an Annie oh she's a nanny
she's a proper through and through no
she's like an American girl oh so she's
a Hallie
oh yeah no I think she's a highlight you
do
oh my God Camper's so American she's got
like love handles which we love which is
so American no British has love
handles like that's for sure and she's
the short red hair where Annie came in
with the long red hair yes but also like
Camp is so American sorry she's Halle
like no question okay fine agreed also
the book comes out on October 10th and
Hallie and Annie are born October 11th
so they literally get like an exciting
birthday gift the day before their
birthday and they could spend their
entire birthday October 11th yeah it's
very the book is very pairing trap coded
honestly
perfect use but it's not intentional
like the uniforms as we said are
uniforms from where we went to Camp she
has red hair like me I guess I'm just
Parent Trap coded or Parent Trap is
Jackie O coded
I think Parent Trap like came out like
when we were in Camp maybe it was Art
imitating life yeah perhaps there was
the original version but whatever nobody
counts that one nobody counts that one
trust and believe and so I was happy to
report that Michaela loves the book oh I
mean I never doubted for a second
because Michaela values you know good
and I went to Olivia's last night
for tacos at trouts oh I'm so jealous by
the way we had to tell everyone tacos at
trout so when Ben and Claudia were here
last week there was one night where Ben
came in he's like what are we doing for
dinner and we were going to be having
tacos at Olivia's so I was just like
tacos at trouts and he was like what's
tacos at trouts and we both at the same
time were like let's talk with him
with him we knew like this was an
opportunity we had to seize like and we
didn't even need to talk about it or
communicate so we were like trouts we're
going to trouts and we're having tacos
it's like that new Taco Place and for
those who may not know trout is a
nickname Jackie has had for Olivia for
many years it's come and gone in
frequency but she's recently been using
it a lot yeah so we were trying to
convince him there was a place here
called trouts where we were having tacos
and he was like why I would be going out
for tacos we're like it's fish tacos
right now and it's like it's like a
local hot spot like everyone's been
talking about I think we even said like
they went viral on Tick Tock you've ever
seen that place like
and like he didn't want to believe us
because we would with him but we
were so good we were so succinct also I
don't think we told Any Lies like when
we kept saying tacos at trouts we're
like it's so good they have the best
tacos it's true I said that's tacos
right so I was a trout I had tacos I
Trout's last night yum and Michaela
brought out the book to me oh and she
said can we read anti-sax book
and then she sat on the couch next to me
while I read it to her
stop kids are so precious sometimes so
precious and it's like I don't think she
could have known how much that would
mean to me and how much I've been
waiting for that moment yeah and and she
didn't do it for that reason no and
there was no guarantee that that was
gonna happen I could have given her a
book and she's like okay you thanks
yeah I have a lot of books but I prefer
the one with the with the 10
caterpillars right and that would hurt
my feelings but I would understand what
book is that okay
it goes like one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten there's like one
six bumblebees oh yeah I don't know but
she knows that one by heart it's not a
hit in in our house in your house got it
because we're too busy reading counselor
counselor well that's so exciting
everybody make sure to get your copies
like support women in the Arts thank you
so much for coming to my TED talk now I
am exhausted
because I was at the event of the season
last night you were
I really was I went to the Jet game
which for a multitude of reasons was so
fun one because Taylor was there of
course like that was just it was so
exciting to be at the center of like a
cultural phenomena
um two I had the cutest sweatshirt on
that just like made me excited to like
when you look good you feel good even
though oh my God I got roasted
on Tick Tock like I had four videos go
crazy viral everyone wanting to eat my
ass alive for my choice in pants okay
let's talk about the pants
okay so I did a couple get ready with me
is wearing uh getting ready for the
event like what outfit should I wear and
I had this crew neck it's like a it was
from Etsy it was actually a toaster
owned Etsy store and so it's just a
white crew neck and I was like how
should I style this like I could not
figure out how to style it and I
realized once everybody came from my ass
on Tic Tac like the reason I couldn't
figure out how to style this like look
cool but like still comfortable for a
sports game is because I don't own a
single pair of jeans right and everyone
was commenting like what is with all
these videos I try on mini skirts and
trousers like put on jeans and I was
like oh yeah but it didn't occur to me
because I literally don't own jeans like
this this whole style everybody wears
like kind of baggy blue jeans like
straight leg we don't do I own like two
pairs of skinny jeans but I will not
wear them I'm like definitely afraid of
being too no and like to wear skinny
jeans with a crew neck sweatshirt to a
football game like no thanks like try
less I'd rather you'd be interesting
with your big pants trousers then
for lack of a better term basic such as
that yeah everyone was just like why is
it taking four videos for you to realize
you need to wear jeans and I the answer
to that is that I don't own jeans like I
just I'm not a jeans girl yeah but even
if you wear skinny jeans Tick Tock was
still gonna come for you because they
want you to wear their big jeans no
that's what they were talking about like
big I know exactly what the big blue
jeans like what are you are you nuts
seriously like we're five one like how
are we wearing big blue jeans now having
said that I actually did order a pair of
jeans because in my defense I think for
a while like I was sized out of cool
jeans like you can't tell me me and my
big ass would look cool wearing big blue
jeans you know like I just I think
that's maybe it's an insecurity but I
think it's fact
now I'm being a little bit more
experimental with my style because I'm
feeling a lot more comfortable in my
body so I did I'm gonna purchase I
didn't even know what size I am like
what size do you think I am 26. oh
I ordered a 29 and I almost ordered
you're nuts I almost ordered a
30 like I I definitely have you're 26 or
27. I have like um
size and like I could try something on
I'm really like a size six now but it's
like a little like large on me but like
even for me ordering a size six like
it's like like I'm like there's no way
this outfit's gonna fit me like it's
just unbelievable to me so okay 26
or 27 yeah depending on the cut and the
brand and the stretchiness whatnot all
right the Jean saga continues but I want
to try like everyone wears like
everybody looks cool doing it like big
blue jeans like all right I'll try but
it's never gonna look cool on me I'm so
short you should get a pair of jeans I
don't know what they're called like
straight leg that's what I yeah that's
what I got I got them from revolve okay
yeah you wear them I've never seen you
wear big blue jeans no no no no oh gosh
no and certainly not blue really but
when I wear like white jeans I wear a
straight leg black jeans yes straight
leg these days very unfortunately I
think like finding the right pair of
jeans is gonna require me to try them on
in store like I don't think you can
really like order I'll have to order so
many different colors cuts and sizes who
is the time for that yeah
that's going to be a hard day I will
stay off my phone so that's how the day
started like me getting roasted on Tick
Tock for being like chewy and weird my
outfit like was weird but whatever I was
running late and I had a good time but I
actually liked the way that I looked
like everybody was coming for me but I
thought I looked cute you did look cute
I looked fine I didn't look amazing but
it's fine it's fine and I had the best
time first of all like we had amazing
seats shout out how did you get those
seats
Ben saw for celeb
the Jets gave them to us whoa which was
extremely generous they did say somebody
canceled last minute so this is why we
got like such good ones oh you know what
I said next to who Kirsten Daly
as in Carson Daly yeah it's confusing
because you were also with our friend
Kristen so I was like are you trying to
tell me you sat next to Kristen was that
a coincidence I did sit next to Kristen
and Kirsten and Kirsten did you talk to
Kirsten no I didn't he was with the sun
I wasn't gonna like be a freak what's it
called when you sit where you sat
because it wasn't courtside
field size
no I don't think there's a word for it
what yard line were you at 50. whoa yeah
like they were like chef's kiss and let
me tell you like your seats were better
than tailors 100 I had the best time
first of all the game was incredible I
know I was watching literally the Jets
could have won had it not been for a
multitude of factors one like the ref's
cheating like not to be such a
footballer like that but like for real
they were cheating like holding ever
heard of it ref it was really
infuriating people but I was also
sitting around so many Kansas City
Chiefs fans that like when they cheered
I was confused because I'm like is this
good or bad like it was very confusing
um so there was cheating involved which
is always great and then like
it was like 23 20. the Chiefs couldn't
get a touchdown so they kicked in and
they got three points because it was 20
20 for a while since 23-20 Jets have the
ball they're in the end zone it's first
and goal that's what I learned first and
goal there all they have to do is go
right there the thing is right there
they got four tries they didn't even do
it and then on the fourth one instead of
Kicking and getting a tie they're like
no let's go for it and just win
this game they lost
well they played respectable game I
think everybody thought when I first
started watching the game I was like
this is going to be like 70 to zero like
how that Miami Dolphins game was last
weekend did you hear about that I did I
I said um I literally turned I'm like
it's gonna be 45 to zero it's gonna have
to stay for the whole time yeah they
didn't embarrass themselves they played
amazing they did good work for Taylor
and lots of chatter about Zach Wilson
the new quarterback who was like never
supposed to play because Aaron Rodgers
was supposed to be the quarterback he's
really young he's fresh I believe he's a
rookie and let me tell you he's getting
his foot wet uh beak wet what is it beak
yeah both he could get both wet but he's
getting super comfortable I've heard His
Name a lot he had some Scandal last year
like Snapchatting his friend's mom
or like his girlfriend's mom something
with a Mom Zach and I were talking about
it that's my king right there yeah and
then he was like stinking up the court
especially after Aaron like he was the
understudy he was never supposed to
right hit the stage
um and then last night maybe he's a
Swifty and he just like wanted to show
up and show out for his girl he's just
like getting more comfortable with the
fact that he is this quarterback like
it's not temporary like it is his job
and I saw his press conference and he
was like listen that thing at the end
where we were like at the finish and we
just had to like go five inches that's
on me like that's unacceptable football
like I actually appreciated his
accountability yeah but he played some
beautiful football and what I said and
he didn't embarrass himself by the way
it was on fire I've only been to I think
one other Jets game before and I think
it being on Sunday night made it more
like electric I think Sunday football is
like a bigger deal than you know Sunday
Day football oh my God it was electric
it was Taylor it was packed oh my God it
made me want to go to another football
game but I think I'd rather go during
the day it's like getting home at
midnight like is annoying yeah
it is
I had the best time I'm like obsessed
with football no it's really nice I was
watching the game last night while I was
doing some work for the redheads and was
quite Pleasant I felt like they didn't
show Taylor enough but I can't complain
I wasn't watching the whole time I was
like half watching because I was doing
work and maybe I missed her but I just
felt like I could have stood to Seymour
Taylor while I had the most incredible
seats I couldn't have been further away
from Taylor if I tried like she was
completely on the other side and like a
few sections up because she was in a
suite so I was like zooming I saw her
like because she was wearing a black
turtleneck and like bright blue jean
shorts like I could see her but I really
I didn't get any like good content of
her so that was annoying but I was
really enjoying the game so much like I
didn't even care oh and there was
toasters of Plenty like it was really
just like a good energy oh and the girl
behind me was wearing the same exact
sweatshirt as me with the NFL logo that
said Taylor's version and so was Ben
yeah Ben uh because it was a toaster own
store she sent a t-shirt for Ben oh cute
she was really sweet cute so he didn't
have to run to Bloomingdale's and buy a
600 shirt no even though you know he
wanted to speaking of this weekend we
recorded a really great podcast episode
that's what we did on Saturday and we
like didn't even talk about it because
it was just like the weekend but we
recorded our Naggy wives episode
right we are toasters around the world
submitted their situations with their
husband like am I Justified or am I
really a Naggy wife and it was so
funny she just all kind of commiserate
and unite about the things that our
husbands do that are unacceptable that I
feel better afterwards yeah I felt
better afterwards too I feel like we all
felt really seen so if you want to
listen to that head over to patreon.com
toast
you better yeah girlies never stopped
working for you never ever so it's like
a great weekend full of fun I spent a
lot of time alone because Ben was on a
work trip so oh I watched I'm now
officially like caught up with Bravo I
feel like I've been so slacking in my
bravo content I watched all of Roni and
all of Salt Lake City well Salt Lake
City is only on episode four
um and it's just there's so much to talk
about and now that I'm like back I have
been like talking to all my friends
about it because I'm like what does
everyone think I'm like delayed but Roni
is so interesting to me like it's really
it's such a different show it is I
wouldn't say there's one thing that's
similar
to the old franchise in the sense that
like they go out a lot and they like are
always having cocktails like I've never
seen any of them drunk so far in 11
episodes and while I think Roni was
really extreme towards the end where
every single episode was somebody what
multiple people getting completely black
out having fights incoherently and then
waking up the next morning and not
remembering it like it was just
frustrating you couldn't even follow a
storyline this time like nobody really
is like getting like even like remotely
drunk they're all just like drinking
cocktails the whole time which is like
good and healthy of course but I feel
like somebody like needs to get really
drunk like for the sake of the plot
honestly yeah or like it feels like
they're just not letting their guard
down because you they're not you're too
Savvy at this point like you've seen
what 15 years of reality TV yep and you
don't want to be that person and these
are all like smart women so why would
anyone do that let me say the show is
not incredible but it has really great
qualities and one of them is that like
every single one of these girls with the
exception of Brynn because I think
Bryn's apartment building doesn't let
her film so we don't know what her house
looks like they amazing beautiful
apartments and all over different
neighborhoods in the city all like you
know some classic some Brownstones some
Loft and it's the real estate is
fabulous like really truly Jenna lines
apartment is amazing jessil's apartment
size Brownstone like it's really it's a
fabulous group of gals in terms of their
Lifestyles and they I would say I I
don't think any of them are actual
Housewives they all work great that's
what you asked for yeah it's it needs
some work but I also think like the more
this group
becomes a group they're not a group of
friends you know their cast mates put
together right
um the more that they become a group
with history like the more time I do
think it really does have potential
great
yeah so I felt good like I'm all caught
up I use my time wisely this weekend I
use my time wisely as well because I
read the redheads book fourth Wing which
is a book that has kind of swept the
nation it's fantasy uh the next the next
book comes out in November so it's going
to be a series like it's a very Hunger
Games people said it's like Divergent
reminds me of Game of Thrones Twilight
everything it was amazing really how do
you have to read it okay it's so good
you have to like be patient with it
because you're entering a new world so
they're like describing all these things
you have to understand like how the
dragons work and everything you know
it's kind of like Game of Thrones like
that I've never read a book like that
that's like not based in reality yeah
I've never read a fantasy book like that
where there's all of the like I have to
understand the world the Utopia yes but
it's worth it and then the next book
comes out in November so like the end
will have you hooked and you don't have
to wait that long for the next one okay
I think it's gonna be like our best
episode of the redheads ever wow because
the book is so popular so so many people
are interested and then there's so many
different like theories and conspiracies
and what's gonna happen and there's so
much fodder and I think also all four of
us loved it I believe I haven't heard
from Dana yet I could see her having
issues with some of the writing because
it's like yeah then it's also smutty
yeah I'm reading Carrie Soto right now
and then I'll do the fourth Wing yeah I
think you would really really like it
I'm really really excited about it I'm
excited to be back with my girls we took
a month off of the redheads oh my God
and I did redhead support women yeah I
didn't read at all since I've given
birth and so I had to read a book and I
really honestly did not have the time
that I made the time I'm so glad that I
did it was really nice to like just get
into something good
I'm so glad so if you were debating
reading along with us this month pick up
fourth Wing the episode's gonna be bomb
the girls are back
and I think we have great stories today
we do have great stories today so I
think without further Ado I'm so down
it's time for them the fast side stories
that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by hatch the
restore 2. so as we get older our
responsibilities and challenges are
increasing which can cause our stress
levels to rise prioritizing quality
sleep is one of the best ways to take
care of yourself instead of lingering on
your phone before bed make sleep your
simplest self-care routine with hatch
restore too I am all about low lift
Wellness things like I'm not going to be
out here like coal plunging but I
believe in Wellness but realistically
like I'm not going to be putting things
in my life that are not really
sustainable and the hatch is my absolute
favorite I've had one now for a few
months and now that we're working with
them I'm so excited about it so think of
the hatch restore to as your bedside
sleep guide it's an ally in rest the
Innovative all-in-one dream machine is a
sophisticated sound machine a light and
an alarm clock that's beautifully
designed for your bedside table so the
way hatch wakes you up is so civilized
and I think it really makes an impact on
how you
feel the rest of the day like not being
woke It Up by crazy sounds or Crazy
Lights like it's very peaceful it's
slowly it starts waking you up 30
minutes it's very slow I find myself now
waking up before my alarm with that
light it's just I love the hatch
good rest allows you to be the best
version of yourself which is why the
hatch restored 2 was engineered to help
you form healthy sleep habits for Life
your hatch teaches your body when it's
time to sleep and when it's time to rise
with light and sound cues I love also
just like reading with my light
um it coaches you through meditations
mindfulness exercises that transform the
time before and after sleep into restful
rituals right now hatch is offering our
listeners 20 off your first purchase of
a hatch or a store too and free shipping
at hatch.co toast sleep deeply and wake
gently with a hat to restore too go to
hatch.co toast to get 20 off in free
shipping that's hatch.co toast today's
episode is also brought to you by Honey
Love there's nothing worse than
suffering in an uncomfortable bra
thankfully honey love has revolutionized
the bra game you can upgrade your
traditional bras that use comfortable
uncomfortable underwire and bulky
Fabrics that are trapping heat inside
your bosom honey loves bras feature
supportive bonding that eliminates the
need for underwire without sacrificing
the lift plus they're made with fabric
that's so soft it feels like a second
skin you'll immediately feel and see the
difference it's next level comfortable
you'll forget you're wearing it for a
limited time you can get honey love for
20 percent off
your entire order when you use the
lincolnylove.com toast support the show
check them out at honeylove.com forward
slash toast so that feeling when you get
home from a long day and you immediately
want to take your bra off don't know her
with honey love you'll never experience
that again because their bras are so
comfortable it really feels like a
second skin you do oftentimes forget
that you're wearing that which is the
point of a bra like we've been so
conditioned to be wearing a straight
jacket no
also Honey Love is just a brand that I
trust implicitly I love their shapewear
I love a lot of their control top
underwear they're um like shorts girdles
I call them like an old lady
um so they just have fabulous products
their bras are amazing Whatever Gets you
hooked on honey love like for me it was
the control top underwear now it's just
a brand that I trust so I got the bras I
get the shapewear I get everything honey
love has you covered for the everyday
look workouts weddings and more they uh
are helping you treat yourself to the
best bras on the market and save 20 off
at honeylove.com toast use the exclusive
link to get 20 off at honeylove.com
toast cinched snatched and lifted it's
hot girl season thanks to Honey Love
today's episode is also brought to you
by the farmer's dog when your stress
brother is the most important person in
your life it is absolutely it is of
utmost importance that you are taking
the best possible care of them and that
really can start with fresh healthy dog
food so we made the switch from like
kibble to the farmer's dog
like now I feel like eight months ago it
is so I have seen immediate benefits
from his coat being so much shinier his
poop's being more regular and just like
more normal sizes his breath oh my God
I'm like very sensitive to breath and
while I know people like love dog breath
I don't Theo's is markedly better it's
just much more manageable and it's
because he's just you know he's getting
healthy from the inside out you know
jokes I do know
so it doesn't matter if your dog is
young or old it's always the right time
to begin investing in their health
helping you with more happy healthy and
full years together and that means more
magical moments with your dog but no
agile no actual magic is required you
give them all the information on your
dog they are sending you pre-portioned
meals so you know exactly how much to
give it's so much easier it comes
straight to your door and it's fresh and
it's healthy and there's no reason not
to if you care about the stress bro in
your life and if you want to get 50 off
your first box of fresh healthy dog food
go to thefarmersdog.com toast you'll get
free shipping and 50 off your first box
when you go to the farmersdog.com toast
go to the farmersdog.com toast to get 50
off your first box and free shipping
thank you the farmer's dog for
sponsoring today's episode you will not
regret investing in your dog's future
together thank you Claudia and welcome
our first Story Taylor Swift cheers for
Travis Kelsey at the Chiefs versus gets
Jets game not the Sharks versus Jets I I
know it's very confusing but it was
cheap spray jets with Ryan Reynolds
Sophie Turner Blake Lively Hugh Jackman
Sabrina Carpenter
Kelsey Brittany Mahomes Austin Swift yes
the gang was all there so it was a
star-studded box as Taylor's rumored
Beau Travis took on the New York Jets
let me tell you how my seat was like
right behind the Kansas City Chiefs
sideline so like Travis was literally
five feet for me the whole time and it's
so interesting to see how like football
and TV actually works because there were
so many clips that went viral of Travis
the first game that she went to he was
like looking up and he's like wow she's
right there you saw that one yeah
and to see it on the ground like the
camera's literally right in your face
like you you know that you're being
televised there's like a big red light
on the camera so I think a lot like like
Travis knows what's going on and he's
definitely you know making a moment out
of it which I totally respect and
appreciate but it was just very
interesting to see how the sauce gets
made it's like literally they just
follow him around the entire time him
and Patrick Mahomes like that's it right
it's not like they really kind of got
him one-handed camera guard in a q
moment like he knows the whole time he's
being filmed just like the whole time
Taylor knows everyone in the stadium is
watching her and the NFL cameras are
trying to get their viral moment too
yeah
it was just interesting because you know
it's a it's a little more orchestrated
than one might see on TV yeah no they're
they're giving us what we want and
they're definitely playing it up for the
cameras I don't think that means it's
fake by any means but it's not like
they're trying to hide how they feel or
their relationship so as opposed to last
time where she went by herself with her
bodyguards to Travis's family Suite she
procured her own Suite I believe she was
in the owner of the Giants Suite because
the Giants also play in that Stadium
okay so that guy has his own so I
believe she either bought or borrowed
from him and stacked it with her whole
crew I'm sure she had like way more fun
not being alone in like a foreign city
not that Kansas City is foreign but like
she doesn't know anyone there
um this time she came like crew deep she
brought um one of her backup singers
who's been her backup singer forever I
was like so excited to see her because I
recognized her from the errors tour and
from like reputation Netflix movie
um Sabrina Carpenter I loved and she's
it's so interesting to me I've fallen
down like a Brittany Mahomes Rabbit Hole
um because of course now Taylor premium
homes is obviously well known especially
in the football world but Taylor brings
it to another level and Brittany Holmes
just gets like trolled for literally no
reason
um and I was like what is the reason
people hate Brittany Mahomes and let me
tell you there isn't one I think people
like were off put by some of her social
content when her and Patrick just kind
of burst onto the scene and like who
cares she was just excited what was her
social content she was just like a
little Rowdy you know she would like
spray people with champagne in the box
and like you know then Jackson was
making tick tocks so like they got like
a bad rap and I was like what is the bad
rap for like what did they do like who
did they kill why does everyone hate
them and honestly I like her so much
apparently she does so much for her
community in Kansas City she's like a
huge Champion for women in sports she's
just like a like a leader in her
community and she gets like so much
for no reason and I need
everyone to stop
okay yeah Justice for Brittany Mahomes
and I feel like she's getting Justice
for herself she's out with Taylor they
were at dinner last week before the game
while the team was in town she's in the
box with literally all the biggest stars
in the world like it's a good day to be
Brittany Mahomes yeah so Saturday night
the night before the game Taylor went
out not with Travis but with Brittany
Mahomes and a bunch of her friends she
ate a private dining room at Emilio's
Balada which is like the best Italian
restaurant in the city and
Travis was out with Patrick somewhere
else but then there was paparazzi photos
of Travis actually leaving Taylor's
apartment Sunday morning in a Range
Rover to head to the game which I
believe is like against NFL protocol
like you have to sleep in the team Hotel
like the night before the game well it's
not we don't know for sure that he slept
at Taylor's but it was the next morning
maybe he went over for breakfast yeah we
didn't see him arrive the night prior
that's true I do wonder I feel like they
do have to stay at the hotel but maybe
if like you have a friend who lives in
town why can't you stay with your friend
what if you have a place in this city
like can you stay at your place no
because even when you're at a home game
I believe if you're at your home game
you still have to stay at a team hotel
by the stadium
I'm almost like 100 sure of that wow
yeah so maybe he just went for breakfast
perhaps or maybe he's getting special
treatment but I also I thought I said he
left in the afternoon
that's what I saw a headline that said
he left in the afternoon so like maybe
he went oh I saw a headline that said in
the morning
interesting
yeah probably it was like 24 p.m yeah I
mean it's confusing morning is like a
it's subject to interpretation it is
plus it was a night game so he had the
day right why not see the town yeah even
though I know that's not how it works in
the NFL and they are on a very strict
schedule
yeah so there's like a lot of rules and
it seems like Taylor I mean Travis might
be getting a little special treatment I
mean for the work he's doing for NFL PR
like I would understand but you know
we're all equals yeah and as long as he
plays well they won the game
I feel like you could make some
exceptions it was touch and go there for
a minute like they almost lost but I
think I made it much more exciting
honestly yes
not to be like such uh
what's contrarian I was kind of rooting
for the Jets for a second there so was I
I mean I'm a New Yorker I really was
rooting for the Jets because I do love
it I just thought it would be an amazing
story like it was so obvious that the
Chiefs are going to win they just won
the Super Bowl and the Jets just lost
their quarterback they they can't catch
a break so I don't care if that makes me
contrary and yeah I was room for the
Jets a little bit Jackie it does first
of all you're born and bred in New York
like it doesn't make you a contrarian at
all first of all calm down
she was rooting for Travis I actually
don't know if people were rooting for
Travis I think everybody is so
interested in this Saga they're just
watching to see what happens okay
okay
yeah I'm not afraid to say it you're not
saying anything crazy calm down I think
it's crazy I think people are gonna
think that's crazy I was 100 rooting for
the drafts like I was wearing a Jets hat
and it was really so exciting because I
think we all walked in there assuming we
had Nary a shot in hell and we only lost
by three points and it was you know
exactly the win to the very end it
wasn't like this obvious thing the whole
time first quarter I was like oh we're
screwed second third and fourth it was
up in the air yeah the Jets should be
proud of themselves plus I'm a fan of
Aaron Rodgers that's his team now he was
there he got so he got his surgery and
he got his Achilles surgery done by like
of course the best of the best surgeon
who lives in California he got cleared
to fly back he was at the stadium I
believe he was in the booth like on the
the headset talking to like the players
and coaches oh interesting so he's
trying
good I'm happy for him also I feel like
for the Arc of Taylor and Travis's
relationship they kind of need to
experience a loss because I feel like
then she could really be there for him
and that's how they'll take the next
step but like when everything's always
good all the time it's hard to progress
and grow
yeah I wonder how many more of his games
she's going to attend her tour does pick
back up
I believe at the end of the year so like
right now she's in her off season and
she can really fly and go wherever she
wants and just have fun which is
fabulous because she's worked so hard
for like the last year but she is going
back
where does he play next
pull up the chief schedule
Chiefs schedule but she also has the
Eros tour documentary coming out right
when your book comes out and then she
has a 1989 Taylor's version so she is
going to start have to like looking out
for number one relatively for sure but
she could keep her Sundays open a day of
rest
okay what's today's date
oh next week they're at the Minnesota
Vikings what day
Sunday
the week after that they have a home
game against Denver what day
the 12th but that's errors to our
documentary I feel like the weekday one
she won't go to but a Sunday
okay so then October 22nd she's like
done with her press for eras there
they're playing oh but in
they're playing la
Los Angeles Chargers I thought it was
the Rams Claudia I can't tell you I
thought it was San Diego Claudia I can't
tell you how long me Zach Zach and
Olivia talked about the LA teams
yesterday because we were watching the
Rams game it's Los Angeles Rams now and
Los Angeles Chargers the Chargers came
up from San Diego and now there was Los
Angeles I don't know and I was just
saying how like
no by the way their colors are blue and
yellow it's literally the same colors as
the Rams no and Los Angeles just like
isn't a city for sports aside from for
for football because then except for
like the Lakers I was like okay and the
Clippers yeah they're the exception for
football I feel like everyone like moves
to Los Angeles so they like have their
home team in their heart yeah and
there's no one who like really has like
La Pride
wait I'm so confused first of all like
San Diego deserves love San Diego is a
fabulous City like they need a team yeah
no it's loud so do the Chargers also
play at Sofi
I mean I guess they spent all this money
like billions of dollars on this new
sofa Stadium it's probably like one of
the nicest stadiums in the country I
guess like a stadium that big needs two
teams
I guess but it's also why does one city
need two teams because then my husband
was like oh well it's New York Jets and
New York Giants I was like that's a
state and it's a big ass State it's not
the California Rams and the California
Chargers because we also have the 49ers
yeah San Francisco they have three teams
there and they used to have the Raiders
they left yeah yeah another Vegas wait
very interesting point you make why does
one city need two teams
who aren't even Allegiant to their city
it's not a city with a lot of Pride let
me tell you let me ask you why New York
Giants and New York Jets play in New
Jersey
it's like a logistical thing but like it
actually is so like in
what sort I'm looking for inconsistent
yeah
like I was in New Jersey last night
that's just there across to bear
yeah I mean it's so classic New York
like you need a place with enough space
for an arena
close to New York which isn't the
capital but it's like the the city of
New York
um I guess we're going to Jersey but I
don't understand why not Long Island or
Hudson Valley or Westchester Westchester
yeah I don't understand but at least the
Buffalo Bills figured it out yeah don't
forget about the Buffalo Bills it's
really hard not to but hailee
steinfeld's helping she is helping now
let's talk about the guests in
attendance with tailored because she's
really been in her Blake and Sophie era
so they of course attended then Blake
brought her husband Ryan who brought his
friend Hugh Jackman who
is really funny that he was there yeah
he's definitely like an oddball like and
I wouldn't you know have thought he
would he would have been there no but
he's really good friends with Ryan I'm
sure he likes football to some degree
he's newly single right you gotta get
out on the town do we ship him in Sophie
do we ship him in Sabrina
no we don't it's also really weird for
me to see Taylor and her big tall
friends like hanging with such a shorty
I mean it makes Sabrina look so short
it's weird because Sabrina and Sophie
are probably the same age or around the
same age and it just looks like she's
their kid
I feel like Sabrina's probably a little
younger than Sophie Sophie's 27.
Sabrina's probably 20 I would say 24.
right so they're like in the same age
group but like it does not feel that way
no it looks like like Taylor's little
sister's friend yeah Sabrina's 24. oh
okay also I fell asleep last night
thinking about Sabrina and Taylor Swift
I love their friendship and I love that
she opened for her on the era's tour in
South America
and I'm so sorry but like I have to
bring up the Olivia Rodrigo of it all
like it's really so bizarre to me and I
definitely think there's bad blood
between
Olivia Rodrigo and Taylor Swift like
it's honestly at this point there's no
doubt in my mind
um and we could you know wax on about
what that's about for an eternity but I
I think that the friendship with Taylor
and Sabrina is so interesting and I
don't think it's like a direct thing
like Olivia Rodrigo I'm gonna be
friends with Sabrina Carpenter I really
feel like Taylor feels I think when we
all look back on like that first album
in the driver's license I think we all
feel like a collective regret for how
Sabrina Carpenter was treated during
that time when she really didn't do
anything wrong yeah and I feel like her
friendship with with Taylor's friendship
with Sabrina Carpenter is kind of a
reflection of that like whether she knew
it or not her hyping up Olivia rodrigue
at the time it made the whole driver's
license it made the whole thing bigger
like once Taylor got involved it was big
and then it got bigger yeah and in the
end it resulted in like the bullying and
the tear down of Sabrina Carpenter who
quite literally did nothing wrong in the
words of Sabrina Carpenter all because I
like to boy like she didn't do anything
wrong and I feel like Taylor bringing
her into the fold and having her you
know come out with her and then open for
her is all just like her way of trying
to like correct the situation and swage
maybe some of the guilt yeah I think
that's fair
like I think we're all guilty like when
we were also involved like Sabrina
Carpenter literally didn't do anything
wrong and she became this like crazy
villain she got like crazy death threats
like she didn't do anything yeah I also
don't think Joshua Bassett did anything
wrong me neither and I don't think
Olivia Rodrigo did anything wrong in
writing about her feelings like that's
what being a singer-songwriter is but I
do think there was more that she could
have done at the time to like stop
people from attacking Sabrina Carpenter
you know
she kind of just let it all play out and
stood back she didn't like the fire but
I do think there's like a responsibility
at some point that's how I feel about
like when Selena Gomez's fans like go
crazy after Haley Bieber like some Haley
I mean Selena Gomez has stepped in and
been like stop and there's power in that
honestly and yeah I'm trying to think
about what is best in like where it goes
so wrong but then it's just like what's
wrong with people yeah I know I know
what's wrong with people like why are
you sending death threats like get a
life
like
because someone's dating someone who
broke up with someone else there
literally was no cheating nothing like
what's wrong with people
it's an amazing question and one that
I've thought about at length and have
come to absolutely no sort of conclusion
for I
I don't know
neither do I
anyways I'm happy for Sabrina it's funny
that like she was hanging out with you
Jackman like he literally could be her
grandma yeah three times her age
three times her height
and that's the thing about Taylor like
she's bringing together this kind of
ragtag group of gals and guys yeah no it
was a great crew
it really was and it made the game so
exciting at home in the stadium I was
really really grateful to be there and
I'm So Into football like not me getting
excited tonight's Monday Night Football
like who's playing who's playing sharks
first Jets
I hope so that'll kind of probably be
the Super Bowl
yeah okay wait who do you think will be
in the Super Bowl
I really I like I have a lot of Hope for
the 49ers I'm like a bit and they are
incredibly good they're killing it Brock
Purdy Christian Kyle George like the
crew I actually think they have a chance
but that's if they beat the Eagles like
they're in the same league
right and I feel like the Kansas City
Chiefs are definitely the best in their
league like they're going to be the that
team but then the other league I don't
know who is gonna I feel like it could
be Kelsey V Kelsey again but I would
love for it to be the 49ers versus the
Chiefs has that ever happened where the
same two teams played in the Super Bowl
two years in a row I believe I think it
will be the 49ers in the Super Bowl
and I don't know enough about who's on
the other type uh side I don't know if
it'll be the Chiefs again
you don't know it's always someone
random
it's so true also Joe burrow what team
is he on
Jaguars no they're it's black and red
that's those are the colors
I mean orange and red
The Bangles Cincinnati Bengals thank you
oh they were in the Super Bowl two years
ago no and like they're always really
good would love for them to get a chance
you know there's so many good-looking
footballers who deserve the chance to be
on the super every time I encounter a
new team
and meet the players and hear about
their stories like I find something so
lovable about them I really do that's
the hard part about being a football fan
and an empath
it's true and being someone like
obsessed with celebrities in pop culture
because there's always a connection to
be made
like one of my favorite people on social
media right now is Hannah Anne from The
Bachelor she's like so out of Bachelor
world she is engaged to a football
player I believe she believe he plays on
the Cults go Indiana you know go Indiana
I mean now I live in Florida I've got
three teams that I can root for oh and
then the Alex Earl like go dolphins go
Dolphins the Dolphins crushed last week
I actually feel like dogs and then they
lost jacket they lost like really bad
yesterday oh did they cause I was about
to say they're going to the Super Bowl
they're not um but then it's like oh my
God Olivia Culpo go Niners Sierra like
there's so many players worth rooting
for based on who they're dating Haley's
time they'll go bills right like I could
find like that's what's exciting for me
about being team agnostic when it comes
to football is like I could watch any
game and find someone to root for yeah
me too
no I'm obsessed it's really really nice
so that's your sports recap for today I
know there's a handful of doubters
non-believers who want us to stop
talking about sports but we can't be
stopped
no we're not like other girls like we
love football no and like there's always
going to be something at the toast where
it's like that is the topic of the month
or the season whatever it is like it was
Kardashians for so long for so it was
Royal stuff for so long like now it's
football like this we're in our football
season it's just excuse us for
diversifying our portfolio like yeah
it's Taylor like it's always there's
always going to be something so if
whatever the flavor of the month is it's
not for you like I'm sorry but get on
board it's fun we're just having it's
fun
get on board it's fun yeah
get on board it's fun and nothing goes
together like football and chili
oh man it's so true the fact that like
football is really like a food activity
does make it more fun it's also fashion
it's it's every everything everything
we've been missing out we really have
I'm like mad
okay moving on to celebrity fighter okay
Pete Davidson crashed his SUV while
leaving his stand-up comedy show after
his reckless driving charge so Pete
Davidson crashed the side of his car
after leaving his stand-up comedy show
at the will turn in LA on Saturday night
the SNL Alum who entered an 18-month
diversion program in July following a
reckless driving charge hosted an after
party when he left around 11 pm and
eyewitness saw him swipe his car against
the side of a wall while exiting the
venue
yikes I'm trying to think because I
performed at The Wiltern and I'm trying
to think sometimes like the back alleys
where you go to the stage door are
really narrow but if I'm remembering
correctly the wilterned one is huge like
there's so much space yeah yeah it looks
like he's got kind of a wide berth I
also would say like he's from Staten
Island he might be like me who like
didn't grow up driving like if I was
leaving The Wiltern at 10 p.m even if
you take an Uber I would take an Uber
but if I did happen to be driving like
yeah I'm gonna swipe some so true
no the thing is the fact that this was a
swipe not like a crash is very
interesting and there's also like
Paparazzi taking pictures like I imagine
it was a stressful situation it's just
bad in light of his last crashing into a
home with his girlfriend and now he's
just like the car Crasher but I always
say talk by the way how him and Chase to
be wonders broke up and he's dating
Madeline Klein we're going to talk about
that in a second but I also think he's
probably not a good driver because he
probably drove late growing up as a city
kid that's my take
I think on Staten Island it's very
Suburban I do believe you actually do
drive like in high school in Staten
Island I'm just saying like maybe it's
less about what Pete's going through
mentally and more about him being a
really bad driver
no it's anything is possible in this
lifetime but I'm my money's going to be
on like
what's going on with Pete Davidson
what's going on with Pete Davidson is a
question to be asked and also like why
not get a chauffeur
when you're so famous there's just no
reason you should ever be driving
yourself especially it's a big night for
you you probably want to celebrate you
don't need to focus on the road let a
professional chauffeur chauffeur you
around and you can enjoy maybe cuddle up
to Madeline in the backseat like why
everybody got to be doing everything all
the time like pick a car some people
driving's just not for them
I would say that about you for sure yeah
I'm gonna give it another shot but what
if it's just not for me it's so
important to like recognize things that
are for you and things that are not for
you you know yeah so let's talk about
him and Madeline like who really thought
that he was gonna like every time
someone like continues their pattern
I'm just like Oh I thought we were
done no and the thing is I've I don't
find it shocking that Pete Davidson's
dating Madeline Klein I really plan to
shocking that Madeline Klein is dating
Pete Davidson like
at this point I wouldn't want to be one
of those girls like and with Chase Suey
wonders it actually made sense because
she's relatively unknown so like that
really was like a good PR move and I
think they met on a set and I feel like
he might be the type of guy once you're
in a room with him like if he Woos you
it's like I don't care what the people
say or what the haters think I love this
man so like if he can get you to that
place of like falling for him then all
that stuff Falls away but it's like
how and why did Madeline embark on this
relationship yeah and I just don't see
her wanting to be like another one in a
line that's why I was surprised when Kim
dated him like you just want to date
someone that everyone has dated to the
point where it's almost like a joke now
and now Kim dating had made it even more
of a choice yeah it just like continues
every time it just gets crazier and
crazier but that's why I really think
there's something so magnetic about him
that like there has to be being like I
don't care what the people say I love
this man there has to be something like
that I love Madeline Klein I recently
fell into like a rabbit hole of her and
Kelsea ballerini like being friends
which I love and I think she's like a I
think she's like similar to Pete in the
sense like of course she's so beautiful
and talented but I think she really has
this like way about her this kind of
like kind of Markle Sparkle like people
are really drawn to her and so obviously
like the coupling makes sense but I
don't know it's like unoriginal I kind
of expected more from Madeline honestly
I was like really looking forward to his
shoes gonna date after John Bay
the couple makes a lot of sense if they
would stay together I would support it
but until they're together for enough
time I'm not paying attention how does
that sound it sounds like exactly what I
was thinking but couldn't verbalize so
thank you so Jerry's out
Jerry's out but also like Pete take a
car take an Uber take a taxi hire
chauffeur at black Lane like there's a
thousand things driving's just not for
you
and driving's not for everyone
sad but true it's a sad truth are you
ready for our next story yes
speaking of Pete Kim Kardashian is back
in bed with Balenciaga she didn't walk
in the show but she posed for the
Brand's lookbook so fans are confused
concerned because Kim is with Balenciaga
again she didn't actually walk in their
fashion show at Paris fashion week but
she did pose for the Brand's lookbook
the reality star was included in the
runway looks provided by the brand
Following the show on Sunday in Paris
France
um and Twitter account tweeted that Kim
um re Kim at Balenciaga demna just told
this person who's like a fashion person
uh told me at the after party that Kim
is actually not not in Paris anymore she
left after the Victoria Beckham show and
party and they just shot her for the
lookbook since she wasn't here whatever
she's still like working yeah I guess
she would have walked if she was in
Paris wasn't in Paris so she's she's
affiliated with the brand once again
I find this so odd and like incongruous
because
and this is the conversation we're
having with the current season of
Kardashians like Courtney's like all you
care about is like what people think of
you and like money and Deals and this is
so bad for Kim's image
that it seems like such an odd sacrifice
but at the same time what we know about
Kim and I think she would admit this
herself is like how desperate she is for
validation from the Fashion World from
like these Legacy Brands these big
fashion houses like Dolce Gabbana she'll
throw her sister under the bus like
Balenciaga she'll throw morality under
the bus like she really is so desperate
to be taken seriously and be like a
serious person in a a respected figure
in the fashion world so like I get like
that for me my understanding is like
that's why she's doing it but at the end
of the day she is so
image obsessed understandably so that
this is there's anytime she wears like
there is Backlash and like it just it
makes people think less of her so I find
it shocking that she would continue to
do it yeah I don't understand it and I
don't have a theory as to why she's
doing it I don't think it's just for
high Fashions approval because there's a
ton of Brands she could work with in the
high fashion space and so if she was
able to like end her relationship with
them after you know those images then
why would she resume it especially she
just worked with Dolce she could have
done something else she could have done
right more Dolce
yeah like Kylie did acne Studios I'm
sure there's not like a limited amount
of brands that want to work with her if
she wanted to be like Louis Vuitton is
like a million celebrity Zendaya Sophie
Turner they have like a million
celebrity ambassadors I don't know I
feel like she has a lot of options yeah
she's she works with Fendi for skims
like right so
it's not just that and I don't have a
theory as to why
she continues to do it especially
because maybe I was thinking maybe she
signed what a three-year contract with
them and like she has to finish it out
but then she still like wears them in
her casual time off duty yeah yeah so I
perhaps it's just like a personal
relationship with the creative directors
and like the team there and she loves
them and wants to work with them it's
like and I think you said it and it's so
true at the end of the day like the
looks that are being turned out for
Balenciaga are not even like giving
gorgeous High fashion obsessed model I
can't wait to get my hands on it it's so
like ugly and tired yeah so to keep
going back when there's so much at stake
and it's a risk when it's it what is the
benefit maybe she has personal
relationships with the creative teams
there and doesn't believe in her heart
of heart that they are bad people who
are exploiting children like and she's
you know it's kind of like Mila nashin
writing the letter right right right
right right
maybe it's that okay go off
go off
it's not for me go off in the spandex
yeah but speaking of good fashion
campaigns
no no you don't want to speak of them
no I do but you need to speak are you
aware that you have a job to do today I
am I aware that's rude am I aware no I
was just saying like you were
steamrolling into the fourth story well
I really so much work that needs to be
done I really wanted to hit my Segway
and then I was going to circle back to
the work that I needed to do oh I
honestly I thought you had forgotten for
real no no no no I did not forget we're
gonna speak of good fashion campaigns
and there's a really good high fashion
one but there's also a fashion campaign
that we need to speak about and that is
Charlie weinrude for Dreamland baby
Charlie weinerab for Dreamland baby
agreed because Street land baby is a
sponsor of today's show Dreamland baby
has the weighted swaddle I've spoken
about the weighted swaddle before and
how it is amazing and it's a game
changer for moms caretakers babies it's
been a game changer for Charlie so last
time I talked about Dreamland swaddle I
was saying I love it because it
obviously has the weighted sleep sack
which is pretty much like what a gravity
blanket does for you the weighted
swaddle does for the baby it's just
relaxing they can get calm they can go
to sleep it's wonderful I was using it
arms out up until this point but I don't
know I hit a Breaking Point like some
last week or the week before where I was
like I'm putting your arms in because he
kept startling and waking himself up the
startle reflux happens until three
months old so I put his arms in and the
reason why I didn't do it at first is
because he he's fought himself out of
every swaddle I'm like the boy doesn't
like to be swaddled I use the Dreamland
swaddle to swaddle his arms in
peace on Earth it it is that velcro the
way that it's just built it was so good
for his arms he wasn't fighting he
couldn't get out of it wasn't even
trying because he was so at peace so I'm
here to say not only is the Dreamland
swaddle amazing weighted arms in arms
out but the velcro to keep the arms in
it's a superior swad dull so I love
Dreamland baby swaddle for my babies go
to
dreamlandbabyco.com and enter our code
toast at checkout to receive 20 off
site-wide and free shipping this offer
is for new and existing customers right
now it is the only swaddle we are using
in our house because this is the only
thing that brings us some peace quiet
and wonderful sleep so if you are
looking for some sleep Solutions
Dreamland baby swaddle check it out also
solutions for Bebes The Braun
thermometer
unfortunately part of being
a parent is watching your kids get sick
and it's just par for the course
especially the older they get they're
out there kids have germs and it's just
something you need to accept but when
they are sick you want to have the right
tools on your hand
s uh both hands is fine which is why I
love the brown thermometer not only does
it take baby's temperature accurately
but they also have so many great tools
for parents to track babies sickness
healing getting better sharing
information with your doctors a fever
and newborns can be more concerning than
a fever and toddlers so they have fever
thresholds that you set your thermometer
to what age your toddler is and they
will let you know if that is a
concerning fever they also have an app
where you can plug all this information
in and keep track of how your kids are
doing especially with the multiple kids
it's hard to keep all these numbers
apart so the bronze smart thermometer is
the best thermometer on the market I've
been using it all the time visit Amazon
search for bronze smart thermometer and
use code 20 toast at checkout for 20
percent off your order that's Amazon
search bronze smart thermometer and use
code 20 toast for 20 off of your order
these are two baby products that I
genuinely love use pretty much every
single day around here recommend highly
now I can talk about the other good
fashion news
other than Charlie for dreamlands for
Dreamland baby
Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny flaunt
their romance in a stylish new Gucci
campaign now this is how you do fashion
this is no this is how you launch a
relationship how you launch a Gucci
campaign a relationship how you partner
with a brand right all of it Kendall
Jenner and Bad Bunny are showing off how
smitten they are with each other in the
latest Gucci campaign in photos posted
to the Brand's Instagram on Saturday
the two pose together as they carry the
Gucci valigaria travel collection
through an airport so there's a video of
them just like taking a few steps
through an airport catching flights and
feelings yeah and some pictures to go
along with it as well where they're they
look like paparazzi photos of the two
You Know It's So Glamorous it's just a
simple no it's like an art imitating
life I actually thought like the
creative Direction This was genius on
Gucci's part however they got both of
them to agree to do this because
Kendall's notoriously private about her
relationships like none of her
boyfriends are really ever on the show
and apparently on her Instagram so this
is a kind of crazy public for her which
was shocking but and she did it in a way
that she's comfortable with like
modeling for a high fashion brand it's
fabulous I'm shocked but it's fabulous I
feel like also he's into it too because
I feel like maybe her other boyfriends
were private themselves and wouldn't
have gone for something like this so
that makes you want to be private but
when you have someone who's used to
being in fashion campaigns and is such a
big star it's like well let's do our big
star things together it's exactly like
Taylor and Travis let's do our big star
Tings together when it turned Joe yeah
quiet sleepy over there right quite
sleepy
um yeah and I think Kendall has really
been making like major waves at Paris
Fashion Week like this was a really good
PFW for her of course this Gucci thing
she closes caparelli show with the big
hair friend fine outfit she walked as
Jenna lions for Victoria Beckham she uh
as the new face of L'oreal L'oreal had a
huge fashion show under the Eiffel Tower
it actually looked sick and Kendall had
like this kind of a choreographed Runway
thing it was beautiful like it was
actually really really really cool it
was really cool it was cool to see her
even though I know she wasn't dancing
but people dancing around her and her in
the middle made it look like she was
dancing it was more of like a
light-hearted show I feel like so many
of the Paris fashion shows are so
serious and for scaparelli like she got
dragged for walking the way that she
walked even though all the models were
they were clearly told to walk like
freaks so when you're a model you just
do what you're told yeah I didn't even
think it was that weird I've seen much
weirder model walks when they walk so
angry huffing yeah down the runway I
felt like it was one of those like
classic you know when you watch like
movies from like 1940s that's how like
fashion shows used to look it was just
like women parading around a room that
was the Bye by God like I didn't think
anything of it and her sister was there
like I thought it was all cute the
internet has a way of making everything
just ruinous no negative negative yeah
she literally did nothing wrong but
she's kind of been killing it like she's
really in the in the press a lot like
not for the show not for her like for
her line of work which is modeling and I
thought it was a fabulous Paris Fashion
Week to be Kendall Jenner yeah I feel
like she had taken some time off even
maybe admittedly when she walked like
one show for Prada last year she wasn't
like walking as much so she did Versace
too
I love it for her and I'm happy for her
in her new relationship that obviously
they're real real enough and and serious
enough that they're gonna put it out
there like this yeah even if it says
like it's beautiful images it's a moment
in time right even if it doesn't last
okay so what she was in a modeling
campaign as a model like there are
photos of her ex-boyfriend but it's just
the modeling right like with a fellow
celebrity it's not like she like lifted
up you know her man off the street and
like no it's harmless yeah these two
could have been booked for a campaign
like this how even if they weren't
dating what and honestly I feel like
that's like a an alternate universe how
they could have met yeah or maybe they
met in the ideation phase for this
Perhaps Perhaps so cute it's cute I like
it I really like them as a couple me too
it's like a hot take really no people
just like to hate on her yeah
and sometimes it's warranted but
sometimes it's not it's not yeah it's
not only when she's talking about how
she's really into Wellness yeah and
health
are you ready for our fifth and final
story Claudia yeah it's a story we've
been waiting for
okay months and months because we've
reached a tentative deal the wga and the
amptp reach a tentative agreement to end
the writers strike and the picketing has
been suspended The Writer's Guild has
reached a tentative agreement with the
alliance of motion picture and
television producers so I guess that's
what that stands for to end its strike
after nearly five months the parties
finalize the framework of the deal
Sunday when they were able to untangle
the stalemate over Ai and Writing Room
Staffing levels so they've reached a
tentative agreement which is to say an
agreement in principle on all deal
points subject to drafting final
contract language
yeah it doesn't sound like it's for sure
no but like people can get back to work
while they finalize the deal points
hopefully there aren't that many major
sticker sticking points that would make
them get back on the picket line
yes well now that wga is like nearing an
agreement it's believed that sag will in
the next week like they're one and the
same I forgot that that's like two
separate I thought this was like yeah
strike no they're two separate strikes
right and this is like what Drew
Barrymore was
being like she was being strike striked
for not striking right
um shows are going back to showing yes
today like Jimmy Fallon's back they're
back now because they needed writers
they don't have like sag actors got it
but actually they still can't really
have guests because any sag member going
on to promote a project is in violation
of the strike okay but I thought that
the SAG joined the wga like in support
of the writers
but now they're stuck on the strike
alone
yeah no it was confusing because did
Sago and strike in solidarity with wga
or for their own terms I believe both oh
with the SAG and the actors were worried
about AI
yes everyone was worried about AI so can
AI start writing TV shows can AI start
replicating like you pay a background
actor 25 to do one day of work and then
you use his AI generated face 25
different times as different background
actors in 10 different shows yeah so
they have their own gripes that they're
striking for yes yes separate but
similar issues like streaming royalties
is for writers and for like they have a
lot of the same issues but they're not
negotiating together got it okay so half
well since okay so if wgya was half the
strike and there have a tentative deal I
would say like
we're 25 of the way through
I'd say like 35 40.
okay well end is in sight yes and that
means that talk shows are coming back so
that whole Drew Barrymore Bill Maher
hoopla was literally for nothing if they
had waited two more weeks or if they
just stuck to their guns then like they
wouldn't be doing the right thing anyway
right
I'm happy everyone's getting back to
work like obviously the people who were
striking but also people who were not in
a union who were severely impacted and
like literally not able to work and
didn't have
a union underneath them to help them
right
so it's kind of been like a terrible
thing like I feel like we've been
talking about a lot but like it's really
terrible it's like people's jobs I just
can we all just big rainbows like we did
big cakes and make rainbows like we did
in Middle School
unfortunately not
did you hear I thought you were gonna
pick us a fifth Story I almost picked it
like three times last week but last week
was such good stories that it was like
damn Costco's selling gold bars
yeah I heard that but I didn't think
that would be story material especially
oh my God I think it's so crazy why is
that crazy
uh it's just like what Costco won't sell
they sell mortgages they sell TVs they
sell chicken now they're selling gold
bars like it's inspiring the way they
never settle why is that crazy
everything
no it's just it's shocking
I wasn't shocked by it oh I was because
when I found out that like you actually
can't anymore but for a long period of
time you could get a mortgage through
Costco yeah I was like oh that was
shocking yes so for me like gold bars
like who even can you buy where can you
buy a gold bar can you buy one at a bank
no I don't think so I feel like you buy
it you know at the Gold Underground
the gold district yeah like to me it's
just like kind of crazy yeah
but I guess that's you no I guess I was
already like my Costco
bubble had been popped with the mortgage
like now I'm just like anything in this
world you can get at Costco yeah like
Olivia and her husband never cease to
amaze me like his hearing aids because
he's partially Deaf from Costco they
they get gas at Costco I didn't even
know yeah
they were taking a trip and we need to
rent a car and so we were like looking
on like Avis and they're like let
me check Costco I'm like what half the
price yeah no so really nothing there's
nothing that you could nothing's off
limits there's nothing that you could
say you got at Costco maybe if you told
me you got like a pap smear I'd be
shocked but actually I wouldn't I feel
like because you can get like glasses at
Costco I feel like you could probably
get your eyes checked like at
LensCrafters they have like an
ophthalmologist I feel like they
definitely have like an ophthalmologist
at lenscraft I mean at Costco to like
give you your prescription and that's a
hop skip and a jump from a pap smear
like Dr Kirkland does it all 100 percent
interesting well those are the past size
stories you definitely needed to know
all of them and it was so great to catch
up with you guys tomorrow here's a
scheduling update tomorrow Jax is off
and we have Jake Shane the octopus Lover
from Tick Tock joining me in studio
Wednesday Jax is back correct back on
Wednesday yes Thursday I have had a
burner in studio with me and then Friday
Jack's virtual Jack's virtual this is
virtual by the way yeah audio and video
yeah so I'll see you guys on Wednesday
make sure to pre-order the camera and
the counter if you haven't already New
Jersey toasters come see me Saturday
October 14th books and greetings if you
want to secure your spot before the
event bite length drops call the store
or just wait for the link it's gonna be
so much fun bring your Littles we're
gonna have a blast
and make your little say more more did
you really want more screaming sing it
out loud oh I'm excited for when Usher
does the halftime show and there's going
to be a ASL interpreter who's gonna be
like if you really want more oh my God
actually that's an amazing call the kids
are gonna go wild it should by the way
it should be Miss rage
foreign
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow in studio with Jake Shane
don't miss it love you bye love you bye